ariel winter is teasing another brand  new tattoo I think it's awesome that  people find me interesting on Instagram  the 18 year old shared this sexy crop  top shot to Instagram on Sunday look at  her right forearm you'll see the ink  though it's hard to tell what it is  Ariel thanked her tattoo artist in the  caption and added can't wait to share  soon I'm now an adult no longer like a  little kid Ariel's tattoo collection is  growing quickly she inked this on her  right thigh earlier this year and has  these family members initials on her  ribcage I think now as I've gotten older  and you know I've had so many people  around me learn help me learn to accept  myself and that's been really amazing  arielle also posted this throwback shot  on Sunday wishing her modern family  co-stars Sofia Vergara a happy 44th  birthday I win